[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم زين
العابدين توفيق وبينما نتحدث الان تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى هذه صوره مباشره من
مدينه بوزنيقه المغربيه الجنوبيه الرباط
عشيه اختتام اجتماعات اللجنه المكلفه من
مجلس النواب والاعلى الليبيين بصياغه
القوانين الانتخابيه بعد ان اتفقت على
القوانين المنظمه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه المقبله والتي ستجرى بشكل
متزامن
صور مباشره من كييف وسط حديثنا امريكيا عن
مؤشرات لبدء الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
وهذه البوشتينا عاصمه اقليم كوسوفو غدا
ارسال 700 جندي اضافي من قواته الى كوسوفو
واستمرار الاضطرابات الشماليه البلاد
اجتماع الرئيس الحكومه
بمبعوثيلي امريكي واوروبي
في مواضيع الحصاد ايضا هذه الليله
تصعيد على جبهات القتال في اوكرانيا شرقا
وجنوبا تزامنا مع استمرار التوتر في
بيلجرود الروسيه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تعلن صدها هجمات واسعه النطاق
الجيش الاوكراني يقول ان عجز روسيا عن
معرفه اتجاه الهجوم المضاد يبقي جيشها
متاهبه والبيت الابيض يقول ان اعلان بادي
الهجوم المضاد متروك لكياف
لاول مره تركيب اجهزه مراقبه للتخصيب في
منشئتي فورد
الايرانيتين وكاله التطريه تدعو ايران
لتسريع وتيره اعاده تركيب الكاميرات في
المواقع النوويه الطهران تؤكد تعاونها مع
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه واشنطن
تعتبر الدبلوماسيه الطريقه المثلى لمنع
ايران من امتلاك سلاح النووي
تواصل الاشتباكات غرب العاصمه السودانيه
وشمالها والجيش اعلن سيطرته على شارع
الاربعين
وقلق امامي بشان اوضاع المدنيين جراء
المعارك المستمره بين الجيش والدعم السريع
على وقع احتجاجات المتواصلات للسربيكوسوفو
في محيط مقاري ثلاث بلديات شماليه البلاد
مبعوثان اوروبي وامريكي في برشتينا بعد
بلغراد لاجراء مباحثات حول خطوات خفض
التصعيد
[موسيقى]
هي لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا ما جرى في مدينه
بوزنيقه المغربيه حيث
توصلت لجنه 6 + 6 التي تضم ممثلين عن
مجلسي النواب والاعلى للدوله في ليبيا الى
اتفاق بشان قوانين الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه المقبله طبعا هنالك اعضاء في
مجلس النواب واخرون في المجلس الاعلى
للدوله انتقدوا المخرجات التي سيتم
الاعلان عنها في بوزنيقه وانتقدوا ايضا
اليه عمل اللجنه المكلفه باعداد القوانين
الانتخابيه والاستطاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
في رايكم الى اي مدى او الى اي درجه يمكن
ان يساهم الاتفاق في تخفيف حده الازمه
الليبيه
بشان هذه القوانين رجاء التصويت على النحو
التالي 40% راوا ان المساهمه محدوده عشره
بالمئه اعتبروها مساهمه كبيره بينما قال
50% ان الاتفاق لا يؤثر اطلاقا هذا السؤال
سيبقى مطروحا على منصات الرقميه ويمكنكم
دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز الكيو ار
الظاهر على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
اسرائيل تسلم مصر جثمان الجندي المصري
الذي قتل ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين في معبر
العوجه وسط تفاعل واسع عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بعدما كشفت اسرائيل عن هويه
منفذ الهجوم
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم نبدا الحصاد بتطورات فيروس
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قال مرسل الجزيره
ان الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه اعترضت اهدافا
جويه فوق مدينه الروسيه قرب الحدود
الاوكرانيه للمره الثانيه هذا اليوم مع
سماع دوي انفجارات وقال حاكم المقاطعه الى
الدفاعات الجويه تعاملت مع ثلاثه اهداف
فوق مدينه بيروت ومحيطها مشيرا الى ان
الاجهزه المعنيه تتحقق من اثر هذه
الاعتراضات على الارض
ورغم تكتم كييف المستمر تؤكد مؤشراتنا ان
الجيش الاوكرانيه قد يكون بدا هجومه
المضاد ضد القوات الروسيه اذ تشن القوات
الاوكرانيه هجمات متزامنه في جبهات شرقي
وجنوب البلاد في الوقت الذي تتعرض فيه
منطقه بيلجرود الروسيه لهجمات بريه وجويه
وقال ماسورون امريكيون وفق نيور تايمز ان
هناك مؤشرات الى ان اوكرانيا ربما تكون قد
بدات هجومها المضاد
هل بدات اوكرانيا هجومها المضاد تنفي كيف
قائله ان خطتها تحب الصمت تتحدث موسكو
بنبره اقرب الى اليقين من ان الهجوم
المنتظر قد بدا بالفعل بالنظر الى ميدان
المعارك وتطورات الساعات الاخيره ثم تم ما
يحدث وكانه يهيئ لعاصفه كبرى لكن اي
السيناريوهات اقرب لهجوم اوكرانيا المضاد
قد تبدا الضربه الاولى من الجنوب وتحديدا
من المنطقه المحيطه بزابروجيا والتقدم الى
ميلوتوبول وصولا الى الشواطئ الشماليه
لبحر ازوف وهو ما سيؤدي الى تشتيت القوات
الروسيه في جنوب اوكرانيا والتحول غربا
لتتجمع في خرسون اذا حدث هذا فسيكون الجيش
الاوكراني قد قطع الجسر البري الروسي من
شبه جزيره القرم الى اقليم دومباس وقد سبق
ان اعلنت كييف ان قطع الامدادات اللوجستيه
للقوات الروسيه في الجنوب جزء اساسي من
الاستعدادات للهجوم المضاد وهو يفسر
الهجمات الاخيره التي هزت خزانات للوقود
في كراسنودار وميناء
وبعد عام من حسم روسيا لمعركه ازوبستال في
ماريوبول تعود القوات الاوكرانيه لمهاجمه
المدينه ما ينبئ بان جبهه حرب قد تفتح
مجددا هناك
وبالتزامن مع هجوم الجنوب قد يذهب الجيش
الاوكراني لتشتيت القوات الروسيه من خلال
شن هجمات بعيده المدى تستهدف وسط اقليم
دومباس يترافق ذلك مع معارك على الارض
بفتح جبهات ظنت روسيا انها حسمت مثل مدينه
باخموت وهو ما يبدو انه بدا بالفعل لتخفي
السلطات المواليه لروسيا بان الوضع في
محيط باخموت صعب للغايه اذ اعادت القوات
الاوكرانيه السيطره على مساحات من قريه
بيرخوفكا على بعد تسعه كيلو مترات فقط
شمال باخموت كما تتحدث وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن هجوم اوكرانيا واسع النطاق
جنوب شا فيه ست كتائب اليه وكتبتا دبابات
ومقاتلات حربيه وسرب من الطائرات المسيره
ووفقا لنسخ الهجمات خلال الاسابيع الخمسه
الاخيره يبدو ان التوغل داخل الحدود
الروسيه وتحديدا من منطقه بالقرود برا
وجوا خيار لدى الجيش الاوكراني 11 منطقه
داخل مقاطعه بيجرود تتعرض بشكل شبهي اما
لهجمات صاروخيه او بالطائرات المسيره او
توغلات لمسلحين يعول حلفاؤكيف في الغرب
كثيرا على قدره الجيش الاوكراني على احداث
تغيير بموازين القوه على الارض تقول
واشنطن ان جميع احتياجات اوكرانيا لهذا
الهجوم لببت وان الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها فعلوا ومستعدون لفعل الكثير في
الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله
اليوم يرى كثيرون ان الجيش الروسي هو ثاني
اقوى جيش في اوكرانيا معداته وجنوده واستر
اتيجيته العسكريه وروحه المعنويه نموذج
على حاله الفشل التقديرات تشير الى ان
روسيا فقدت اكثر من 100 الف قتيل في
الاشهر السته الماضيه ولكن يواصل ارسال
موجه تلو الاخرى من الروس الى ما يسميه
بمفرمه اللحم
اما الرئيس الاوكراني فهو يريد استعاده
حدود اوكرانيا المعترف بها دوليا بما فيها
شبه جزيره القرم لكن زيلينسكي لديه غايه
اخرى فهو يريد ان يبرهن على قيمه استثمار
حكومات اوروبا والولايات المتحده في الجيش
الاوكراني
من بيروت العميد الياس حنبل الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي
الامريكيون بحسب تقولي انه الهجوم
الاوكراني ربما يكون قد بدا وهنالك مؤشرات
على ذلك ما المؤشرات التي تشير الى انه
هجوما اوكرانيا مضادا كان ربما يكون قد
بدا بالفعل
زين العابدين هذا الاستحقاق لابد ان يحصل
الطقس مناسب تسعه الويه الى 11 لواء
اوكراني تم تجهيزهم وتدريبهم على القتال
المشترك بين الاسلحه المتعدده اثنين
زياده وتيره التصعيد ان كان في الشرق داخل
الاراضي الروسيه او قصف العمق الروسي ميني
كييف من
موسكو الى الكرملين الى كل هذه الامور تدل
ان هناك شيء يحضر وكانه تحضيرا للارضيه
القادمه ولكن حتى الان لم نرى هذا الزخم
الاساسي في منطقه ما وهذا يهدف او قد يهدف
الى عمليه تضليل واسعه كفتح جبهات متعدده
تشتيت القوات الروسيه تثبيتها في اماكنها
وبالتالي التركيز على نقاط الضعف ولكن يجب
ان يكون
الهجوم المرتقب يحقق شيء ما لتبرير كل هذا
التحضير
يعني هنالك غموض حول شكل هذا الهجوم لانه
نحن نتحدث الان عن هجمات من مناطق متعدده
الجيش الاوكراني يقول انما يحدث يجعل
الروس لا يعرفون من اين سياتي الهجوم
ويشتت الانتباه روسيا هل هذا جزء من الخطه
خطه الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
زين العابدين هذا جزء من الخطه ولكن اليوم
عندما يقول
رئيس دوله نحن جاهزون للهجوم هذه اول مره
يعلن علنا لا عامل مفاجاه عامل المفاجاه
سيكون على المستوى التكتيكي والمستوى
العملاني نتحدث عن منطقه الشرق انا اعتقد
هي الاصعب في هذه المنطقه خاصه في دنيتك
وقد يبدو ما يحدث الان حتى في مخموت
انجازات لجيش الاوكراني تثبيت هذه الجبهه
هذا امر مهم فتح الجبهه وتثبيت القوات
وبالتالي عدم القدره على القياده لاي حرب
من منطقه خرسون لانه عامل النهر نهر هو
حاجز طبيعي مهم جدا يبقى الانجاز الكبير
والممكن بناء لهذه الاسلحه التي اعطيت
والتي تتطلب او تستدعي مناطق سهله
للمناوره دبابات وما شابه قد تكون فقط من
منطقه
ذابروجيا توم كاك والى ميليتوبول وصولا
الى الجسر البري فيما يتعلق بالقرم اين
موقعها من الهجوم المتوقع
القرم هي
جوهره التاج في مشروع الرئيس بوتين وهذا
الامر يتطلب مجهودا اكبر في السلاح في
العديد في الدبابات وما شابه وهذا امر ليس
متوفرا وانا لا اعتقد شخصيا ان الامريكيون
او حتى الناتو قد يدعم اوكرانيا للذهاب
لتحرير او استرداد شبه جزيره القرم لانه
هذا الامر قد يذهب الى تصعيد مضاد حتى
الوصول الى اسلحه غير تقليديه انا اعتقد
اليوم الهجوم هذا الهجوم المنتظر هو هدفه
تحقيق انجاز مهم جدا للذهاب الى طاوله
المفاوضات وهذا الانجاز لن يكون الا عبر
قطع الجسر البري
من بيروت العميد الياس حمض الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى الملف النووي الايرانيه قال مدير
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رافائيل
غراسي ان مخزون ايران من اليورانيوم
المخصب ارتفع باكثر من الربع في ثلاثه
اشهر وفي المقابل قال مسؤول ايراني
للجزيره ان تقرير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه يثبت ان الطيران تفضل دائما
التعاون مع الوكاله اضاف ان حل بعض
القضايا العالقه مع الوكاله واغلاق ماء
وصفها بالادعاءات هي امر في صالح الطرفين
في اجتماع مجلس محافظ الوكاله الدوريه
للطاقه الذريه بفينا بدا ان السجاده
الرئيسيه يدور الان بين الوكاله واسرائيل
رد مدير الوكاله على انتقادات رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين وطنياهو وقال
ان الوكاله لا تنحاز في عملها الى اي
مواقف سياسيه
فيما يتعلق بالمعايير انا اؤكد اننا لم
نخفف من معاييرنا ابدا نحن ملتزمون بهذه
المعايير ونطبقها في عمليه معقده ونحن
صارمون من الناحيه التقنيه حازمون ولكننا
عادلون في الوقت نفسه لم نخفف من معاييرنا
لاسباب سياسيه نتفهم وجود تلك المواقف
السياسيه ولكننا لا ننحاز لها
هنا على انتقادات سابقه لنظمياهو قال فيها
ان استسلام الوكاله لضغوط ايران يعد نقطه
سوداء في سجلها ما اغضب نتنياهو هو ان
تقرير الوكاله الدوليه الاخير ذكر ان
محققيها اغلقوا تحقيقاتهم بشان وجود اثار
يورانيوم في موقع ماريفان وحسب التقرير
فان الوكاله اعتبرت رد ايران بان الاثار
ناجمه عن نشاط منجم سابق تفسير ممكن تشير
السلطات الايرانيه الى نشاط منجمي قام به
الاتحاد السوفيتي المنحل في الموقع خلال
الستينيات غطى السجال الناجم عن الموقف
الاسرائيلي على اعلان جروسي تركيب اجهزه
مراقبه لاول مره في منشاتي فوردو
بطيئا حصل بشان تنفيذ اتفاق مارس الماضي
المتعلق بالمراقبه لكنه اعتبره غير كاف
اما في طهران فقد قال مسؤول ايراني
للجزيره ان تقرير الوكاله الدوري للطاقه
الذريه يثبت ان ايران تفضل دائما التعاون
مع الوكاله واضاف ان حل بعض القضايا
العالقه مع الوكاله واغلاق بعض الادعاءات
في صالح الطرفين واكد استعداد طهران
للتراجع عن السياسه خفض الالتزامات اذا
ابدت الاطراف الاخرى تعاونها تزامنا مع
اجتماعات الوكاله بفينا قال وزير الخارج
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن امام مجموعه الضغط
الاسرائيلي المعروفه بايباك ان بلاده
تعتقد ان الدبلوماسيه هي الطريقه الافضل
لمنع ايران من امتلاك سلاح نووي لكن جميع
الخيارات مطروحه على الطاوله لضمان عدم
حدوث ذلك بما في ذلك تعزيز قدرات اسرائيل
العسكريه في ظل هذه الظروف وفي غياب
مبادرات سياسيه يبدو العمل التقني للوكاله
الدولي للطاقه الذريه غير كاف في التوصل
الى حل يرضي كل الاطراف
من طهران بن عباس اصلان الباحث وفي مركز
الشرق الاوسط للدراسات ومن واشنطن الدكتور
جوزيف
عضو سابق بالمجلس الاستشاري لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه وكبير الباحثين في
معهد تونسي وابدا بضيفي من طهران عباس
اصلاني
ايران توشيط بتقرير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
وافقت على تركيب كاميرات في فوردو
ما الهدف ما الذي تريد طهران تحقيقه بهذا
التعاون الجديد مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه
[موسيقى]
اعتقدوا ان ايران تفهم ان اي جو بناء من
التعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه
يمكن ان يؤدي الى حل المسائل العالقه هذا
ما تفهمه ايران ونحن نتحدث عن موقع
بالاضافه الى موقع سابق تم حل المشاكل
بشانهما بالاضافه الى ذلك ايران ومن اجل
الاظهار اظهار حسن نياتها وافقت على ان
يكون هناك كاميرات للمراقبه وهذا يشير الى
ان ايران من جهه والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه من جهه اخرى توداني ان تحل المسائل
العالقه وهذا التعاون ركز على الحيز
التقني وهناك عمل في الاتجاه التقني يرتبط
انهائي المسائل العالقه هذا التعاون يمكن
ان يساهم في عمليه التفاوض لاعاده احياء
الاتفاق النووي وخطه العمل الشامله
المشتركه وقد استمعنا الى بعض الاخبار من
الولايات المتحده بهذا الشان اذا اي جو
ايجابي يمكن ان يساهم في هذا السياق لربما
اسرائيل لا تحبذ ذلك ولكن نحن نتحدث عن
طرفين يفهمن ان اي ازمه في المنطقه هي اخر
ما تريده المنطقه بالاضافه الى ازمات
مختلفه في اوكرانيا وفي اماكن مختلفه من
العالم وبالتالي هناك جهود لتفادي التوتر
والتصعيد في المنطقه
وهنا اسال الدكتور
جوزيفسيوني يعني فيما يتعلق بهذه النقطه
تحديدا
يعني يعني منذ عام او في الاشهر الماضيه
كان يبدو مساله تركيب الكاميرات امرا صعبا
يكاد يكون مستحيلا كان يبدو ان نتجاوز
الوكاله لقضيه اليوراني والمخاصم الذي وجد
في بعض المقاطع امرا صعبا يكاد يكونوا
مستحيلا نحن نتحدث اليوم وقد تم تجاوز هذه
المشاكل جميعا
ما السياق الذي ادى الى تجاوز هذه النقاط
بهذه السهوله وبهذه السرعه
نعم يمكننا ان ننهي المقابله هنا لانني
اتفق بشكل كامل مع زميلي من ايران اعتقد
اننا نرى سلسله من الخطوات الصغيره التي
تشير الى تقدم على مستوى حل المسائل
العالقه التي اشارت اليها الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه بالاضافه الى امكانيه تحقيق
اتفاق معين يمكن ان يؤدي بنا الى خطه
العمل الشامله المشتركه واتفقوا مع زميلك
ذلك لا ائران ولا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تودان اي نزاع في المنطقه لذلك
نشهد ارتفاع منسوب الدبلوماسيه
وتخفيف من حده الخطابات المرتبطه بعسكره
المنطقه اعتقد ان الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه قامت بعمل جبار في هذا المجال
السيد جروسي الذي نشاهده على الشاشه الان
قام بعمل
في هذه الظروف الصعبه للغايه نحن نعرف ان
ايران قامت ببحوث مرتبطه بالاسلحه في
التسعينيات من القرن الماضي ونعرف انها
انهت هذا الموضوع في العام 2003 المساله
الاساسيه كانت مرتبطه باثار اليورانيوم
المخصب في المواقع والتي تشير الى ان بعض
المواقع التي قالت ايران انها لم تقم باي
بحوث بشان اليورانيوم فيها راينا ان هناك
اثار وتعين بالتالي على الوكاله الدوليه
ان تحل هذه المشكله النقطه الثانيه هي
عوده المراقبه ولقد شاهدنا التقدم الذي
احرز الان ان ايران وافقت على تركيب
الكاميرات والسماح لعدد اضافي من المفتشين
ولكن يجب ان نتنبه ان مدير الوكاله قال ان
هذا جزء مما هو مطلوب وبالتالي نتحدث عن
خطوتين الى الامام بالنسبه الى
العالقه والمراقبه ولكننا لم نقترب الى
المرحله التي نعلن فيها عن الانتصار اي
التوصل الى اتفاق اشمل ماذا بقي
ما الذي بقي حتى نتحدث عن استئلاف مفاوضات
الاتفاق النووي
ما تبقى هو مسالتان مرتبطان بالتاريخ
نتحدث عن
موقعين اخرين فيهما اثار لليورانيوم
المخصب والذي لم يتم تقديم اي شرح بشانهما
هذا اولا ثانيا يتعين على ايران ان توافق
على اعاده تشغيل كل الكاميرات والسماح لكل
المفتشين ان يفتشوا وايضا التعاون بالنسبه
الى البيانات المفقوده لاشهر اذا ما قامت
ايران بذلك سوف تكون قد امتثلت الى
الاتفاق الذي وقع في شهر مارس او الذي تم
التوصل اليه في شهر مارس بين الوكاله
وايران وهذا يغلق الملف المرتبط بالتاريخ
وهذا ما اصرت عليه ايران في شهر ايلول
سبتمبر عندما لم توافق على الاتفاق
الذي تقدم به الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي للع خطه العمل الشامله
المشتركه كان هناك تسليط للضوء على اهميه
اغلاق الملف السابق نحن نحرز تقدما بهذا
الاتجاه لست متفائلا ولكن اقول ان هذا
الامر ممكن راينا سلسله من الخطوات في
الاسابيع الماضيه عدد كبير من الولايات
المتحده من عمان من ايران يتنقلون في
المنطقه ويتباحثون فيما بينهم وبالتالي
هناك امور تجربه وهنالك قنوات تحدث عنها
الايرانيون بين الولايات المتحده وايران
في الوقت الراهن عباس اصلاني من طهران ما
الخطوه المتوقعه التاليه من جانب ايران في
رايك هل هل توقف الامر عند هذا الحد ام ان
هنالك خطوات اخرى
الحقيقه وكما اشار الدكتور سيرينسيواني من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذه
العمليه كانت ممكنه في السابق ولكن ها نحن
نشهد هذا التقدم يجب ان لا نفرط في
التفاؤل هناك بعض الامور الاخرى التي يمكن
ان نتوقع ان تحصل اذا بعض الخطوات التي
ادت الى هذا الزخم الايجابي على مستوى
الوكاله الدوليه التقاديريه نحن بحاجه الى
زخم اضافيه على سبيل المثال تبادل السجناء
بين ايران والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اليوم ايران والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يبدو انهما لديهما اهتمام اكبر من الاطراف
الاخرى بالنسبه الى هذا الموضوع يجب ان
يشارك الاوروبيون كذلك بالنسبه الى اعاده
خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه والعمل على
اختلافات اوروبا حاولت ان تقدم بعض
المقترحات ايضا اوكرانيا اثرت على هذه
المفاوضات اعتقد ان هذه المسائل يمكن
العمل بشانها بشكل منفصل هناك
قلق يمكن التركيز عليها وفي الوقت نفسه
يمكن التعامل بشكل منفصل مع النقاط
العالقه مع ايران بالنسبه الى موضوع
المفاوضات مع الاطراف الاخرى بشان خطه
العمل الشامل المشتركه قد يتم او يمكن
التوصل الى اتفاق لاخياء هذا الاتفاق اذا
اعتقد انه يمكن البناء على هذه الاجراءات
لاننا نشهد الان خطوات ايجابيه في السابق
شاهدنا نقصا او غيابا للثقه اذا يمكن
البناء على هذه الاجراء نشكرك من طيران
عباس اصلان الباحث وفي مركز الشرق الاوسط
للدراسات ونشكر ايضا من واشنطن دكتور
جوزيف
العضو السابق بالمجلس الاستشاري لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه وكبير الباحثين في
معهد كوانسي
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على
المنشات والمواقع الايرانيه حل الخلاف بين
طيران والوكاله الدوريه للطاقه الذريه
ونسال ضيف الحصاد على اهميه التطور الاخير
في العلاقه بين الطرفين
[موسيقى]
الى السودان افاده مرسل الجزيره بالتجدد
القصف المدفعي في جنوب العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وكانت الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع قد تجددت منذ
الصباح في مدن العاصمه الثلاث الخرطوم
والخرطوم بحري وام درمان وافاد مراسل
الجزيره بسماع اصوات اشتباكات بالاسلحه
الثقيله في شارع الغابه والمنطقه الصناعيه
والحل الجديده غربيه الخرطوم كما شهدت
مناطق ام درمان اشتباكات وسمع عدوي
انفجارات متتاليه جنوبيه المدينه وفي
منطقه بحري شمال الخرطوم
على صعيد متصل قالت مصادر عسكريه في الجيش
السوداني للجزيره ان قوات الجيش سيطرت على
شارع الاربعين في يوم درمان بالعاصمه
الخرطوم اوضحت المصادر ان حيه يلعباسيه
وبانت العمده
المتاخمين للشارع الاربعين شهد اشتباكات
وتمكن خلالها الجيش من تدمير سياره تتبع
الدعم السريع والسيطره على سيارتين اخريين
بالاضافه الى تنشيط الشارع الاربعين هذا
واعلنت قوات الدعم السريع سيطرتها على
حاميه عسكريه في مدينه كتم غربيه البلاد
بينما نفى الجيش ذلك
معنى هنا في الاستوديو في الاستوديو
الحصاد ضياء الدين بلال الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي السوداني بدايه نبدا بشارع
الاربعين ما اهميه اعلان الجيش السيطره
على هذا الشارع في الخرطوم نعم هو من شارع
المهمه جدا في ام درمان لانه يربط ما
بالخرطوم من الشوارع التي شهدت
ايام الثوره شهيده مظاهرات كثيره جدا وله
رمزيه بالنسبه
للثوار وللقطاعات واسعه فهو من الشوارع
الحيويه في الخرطوم لقربه كذلك من الجسور
التي تربط الخرطوم بام درمان وتربط
بالخرطوم بحري لذلك تاتي اهميه هذا الشارع
طبعا هذه الاحداث تقع في ظل عدم وجود اي
اتفاقات هدنه في الوقت في الوقت الراهن هل
غياب اتفاقات الهدن هذه زاد من وتيره
الاعمال القتاليه الهدى ذاتها لم تكن
لتوقف الحرب كانت العمليات مستمره حتى في
ايام الهدن في ظل الهدن كان هنالك هجوم
للدعم السريع لبعض المرافق مثل هجوم على
القاعده الجويه او المدرعات فبالتالي هذه
الهدن لم تكن سوى انها هدى اعلاميه فقط
ولمخاطبه المجتمع الدولي بان هنالك رغبه
لدى الاطراف للوصول الى وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار ولكنها لم تكن تتحقق على ارض الواقع
من خلال انحصار العمليات العسكريه او
زياده
فيما يتعلق بالجهود الدبلوماسيه هنالك
مبعوث للدعم السريع يزوروا كينيا والتقى
بالرئيس روتا على سبيل المثال ما الذي
يرمي الدعم السريعي لتحقيقه بافاده مبعوثه
الى دول افريقيا
واضح ان الدعم السريع يتعرض الى بقطعه
عسكريه كبيره جدا وهو محدد من قبل الجيش
بالانتهاء من قوته المركزيه قواته
المنتشره في بعض المناطق فهو يريد عبر هذه
الاتصالات ان يضغط على الحكومه السودانيه
لتستجيب لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار ومن خلال
هذا الوقت تتاسس عمليه سياسيه او عمليه
عسكريه من خلال يتم تقسيم الخرطوم ما بين
مناطق سيطره الدعم السريعهم ما بين مناطق
سيطره الجيش اعتقد ان ذلك هو
ان تلك هي الاهداف الاساسيه بالنسبه لهذه
الزيارات كما ان هذه الزيارات تريد ان
تؤكد بان الدعم السريع لا يزال موجود وانه
قادر على التحرك في هذه الاطرس الدولي حتى
يكتسب شرعيه
وهي الشرعيه التي نزعت منه عبر القرارات
الصادره من رئيس المجلس السيادي
بعزل
كله لا ينظر لما يجري في السودان سواء على
انه خلاف بين طرفين عسكريين على نفس القدر
من المشروعيه لكن فيما يتعلق باهداف الجيش
في المرحله الحاليه اهداف السيد البرهان
ما هي اهدافه في هذه المرحله الاهداف
العسكريه الاساسيه هي التقليل من حجم قوات
الدعم السريع وهي واستهداف القتل القتل
الصليبه في هذه في هذه القوات وبالتالي هو
يريد ان ان تنحسر انشطه دعم السريع خاصه
في المناطق المتعلقه بالاعيان المدنيه حيث
سيطره الدعم السريع على منازل اعداد كبيره
من المواطنين في مناطق مهمه وكذلك يضع بعض
القوات في بعض الاماكن الحيويه حتى يحتمي
بالمنشات المدنيه وكذلك
يحتجز وياسر عدد كبير من المواطنين من
المدنيين ومن العسكريين ويتخذهم كدروع
بشريه فبالتالي هو يريد ان ينزع هذه
الاوراق التي يحملها الدعم السريع ويحاول
ان يساوم بها على طاولات التفاوض ان تنزع
هذه الاوراق عبر عمليات عسكريه كما قلت
قبل قليل تستهدف مجاميع وقوه الدعم السريع
في مناطق مختلفه
والمحلل السياسي السوداني
جدد المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده ستيفاندو جاريك الدعوه لوقفه كامل
الاعمال العدائيه في السودان للسماحل
للمنظمه الدوليه بايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه بالحجم المطلوب الى الشعب
السوداني وقال ان وقف القتال الصايمكن
الامم المتحده بتوفير المساعدات بشكل اسرع
يواجه زملائنا في برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
بعض التحديات الحديثه في توزيع الغذاء
نريد ان نرى وقفا كاملا للاعمال العدائيه
حتى لا نضطر الى التفاوض على اساس كل حاله
على حده من اجل توفير امكانيه الوصول نريد
ان نرى الاطراف في السودان توقف القتال
حتى نتمكن من مساعده الشعب السوداني
بالحجم المطلوب
قال الممثل الرومي الخاص الى افريقيا
الوسطى عبده عباري ان ان القتال في
السودان له عواقب وانسانيه مدمره على تشاد
وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى واكد خلال جلسه
مفتوحه لمجلس الامن الدولي بشان الاوضاعي
في افريقيا الوسطى اكد الحاجه لتوفير نحو
129 مليون دولار لرعايه مئه الف لاجئ لمده
سته اشهر في تشاد فقط
لكم بقى انكور اسودا القتال الدائر في
السودان له عواقب انسانيه مدمره على تشاد
وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى بالنسبه لتشات
ستكون هناك حاجه لنحو 130 مليون دولار
لرعايه مئه الف لاجئ مده سته اشهر بدون حل
سريع وسلمي للنزاع ستكون الاثار وخيمه على
السودان ولكن ايضا على جميع البلدان في
منطقه حوض بحيره تشاد
ولمواجهه الازمه المستمره في السودان يجب
ان ندرك ان التزامنا وتضامننا مع تشاد امر
ملح لذلك نحن بحاجه للعمل بسرعه
لمساعده هذا البلد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الشمعه رئيس وزراء
كوسوفو كورتي في مكتبه بالعاصمه الكوسفيه
برشتينا مع مبعوثه الاتحاد الاوروبي
للحوار بين كوسوفو وصربا وصربيا
والمبعوث الامريكي لغرب البلقان جبريل
اسكوبار وذلك في اطار السائل لخفض
التصعيدي في شمال كوسوفو وكانت قواته حفظ
السلام الدوليه قد ازالت الجزء الاكبر من
الاسلاك الشائكه في محيط مبنى بلديه
البلاد هذا وتتواصل احتجاجات الصرب كوسوفو
في محيط مقاري ثلاث بلديات شماليه البلاد
مطالبين بعدم دخول رؤساء المجالس المحليه
الجدد اليها
معنى من بوسطن السفير فيسكو غارسيتش
الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه المختصه
بالامن الاوروبي والشؤون البلقان في جامعه
بوسطن
دكتور
اريد ان انقل لك ما كتبته وانت شخصيا قلت
ان الولايات المتحده
والمملكه المتحده وللامم المتحده ينبغي ان
تبلغ بالجراد بان هذه ليست لعبه وانه لا
ينبغي التسامح معها لماذا برايك لم تبلغ
هذه الاطراف بالجراد بما تقترحه
نقطه المثيره للاهتمام هي ان الغرب وبعد
التصعيد الاخير الذي شاهدناه في شمال
كوسوفو ان دول الغربيه تركز وبشكل مثير
للاهتمام على قصف واكثر من صربيا اعتقد ان
الدوره الصربي اساسي هنا لان الصرب في
الاجزاء الشماليه من كوسوفو يعتمدون بشكل
كبير على القرار الصربي قرروا ان يقاطعوا
الانتخابات البلديه بسبب بنصيحه من صربيا
بالنسبه اليه ان المقاطعه ليست خيارا ان
كوسوفو اجرت الانتخابات في المنطقه ويجب
المشاركه في الانتخابات البلديه ويجد ان
يقبل الناس بان ذلك سوف يتم وفقا للدستوري
في كوسوفو تفاجا عدد كبير من الناس في لان
الغرب انتقد قصفه اكثر من الانتقادات
الموجهه الى صربيا اعتقد برايي ان هناك
نظره في بعض الدول الاوروبيه وبعض الدول
الغربيه ان هناك ورقه مرتبطه بالرئيس وجده
وهو
انه قائد وزعيم مهم للصرب ويمكن ان يؤدي
دورا في المفاوضات بين الطرفين وفقا للخطه
الالمانيه الفرنسيه هذه استراتيجيه
اعتمدتها الدول الغربيه بعد العام
1995 ولكن اذا ما نتذكر جيدا هذه
الاستراتيجيه فشلت فشلا ذريعا وادت الى
التدخل حلف شمال الاطلسي انا لا اقول ان
هذا الامر سوف يحدث مجددا ولكن يجب التنبه
الى ما يحصل في كوسوفو ما يحصل في كوسوفو
الان ايضا ياتي بنا الى الضغوط على كلا
الطرفين للعوده الى الطابات المفاوضات
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا من
بوستون السفير فاسكو
العلاقات الدوليه المختصه بالامن
الاوروبيه وشؤون البلقان في جامعه بوسطن
يتوجه نحو 800 الف ناخب في الكويت يوم غد
الثلاثاء الى صناديق الاقتراع الاختيار
ممثلين في مجلس الامه
ويتنفسحين بينهم ثلاثه عشره امراه على
خمسين مقعدا نيابيا تمثل 10 دوائر
انتخابيه اتاتي هذه الانتخابات بعد ابطال
العمليه الانتخابيه وحل البرلمان الذي
انتخب عام 2022
انضموا الينا من الكويت مدير مكتب الجزيره
سعد الصعيدي ما هي التوقعات بالنسبه لهذه
الانتخابات هل يمكن ان تفرز برلمانا اكثر
استقرارا
زين هذه الانتخابات هي الثانيه في اقل من
عام قبل تسعه اشهر اجريت انتخابات وتم
ابطالا ثم ايضا اجريها او جاء حل مجلس
الامه وايضا هذه الانتخابات ستكون في غضون
عامين ونصف هي الثالثه اي ان يتوجه
الكويتيون في سنه وسنتين ونصف تقريبا ثلاث
مرات الى صناديق الاقتراض وايضا هي
السابعه منذ العام 2012 حل البرلمان وحاله
الابطال المستمره وايضا حتى انعكس على عدد
المرشحين هنا في الكويت لك ان تتصور بان
عدد المرشحين هنا في الكويت في هذه
الانتخابات وصل الى 200 وسبعه مرشحين فقط
وهو الرقم الاقل منذ ثلاثه عقود منذ
الانتخابات منذ عام
2005 او منذ عام 2006 حل البرلمان تسع
مرات هذا البرلمان وابطل بقرار من المحكمه
الدستوريه ثلاثه مرات نحن الان نحتفل او
نقترب من
عاما في العمليه الديمقراطيه هنا في
الكويت التي حيث ان اول مجلس تشريعي هنا
في الكويت كان في العام 1963 منذ العام
1963 الى اليوم حله مجلس البرلمان حل
البرلمان الكويتي 11 مره منذ عام 2006 في
الخضور 15 سنه فقط حل تسع مرات هذه
الارقام لها دلالات حقيقه وهي التي قد
تشكل حاله احباط كبرى هنا في الكويت قد
تؤدي الى عزوف عزوف الناخبين او عزوف
الناخبين عن التصويت في هذه الانتخابات
بعد ان تمكن الياس من كثير من الكويتين
هنا ولذلك جاءت محاولات هنا ايضا في
الكويت من خلال نشر كثير من اللوحات
الاعلانيه وايضا كانت هناك ايضا وسائل
الاعلام رسميه وغير رسميه تطالب الكويتيين
بالمشاركه
بكثافه في هذه الانتخابات وعدم ترك ايضا
صناديق الاقتراع لان هذه الممارسه يجب ان
لا تغيب عن الكويتين وعن هذه وان يكون لهم
صوت واخراج برلمان رغم حاله الانسداد
السياسي
ولذلك هذه الحالات المستمره من حالات الحل
وحالات الابطال حاجه جاءت نتيجه قد تكون
ايضا حاله احتجاج سلمي ايضا عزوف الناخب
الكويتي اذا ما اذا غدا او في اقل من ثمان
ساعات ستتوجه 800 الف ناخب وناخبه الى 118
لجنه الانتخابيه قد يكون هناك حاله من
العزوف وقد تعتبر هذه رساله احتجاج سلمي
صامته من الكويتيين بسبب حاله الانسداد
السياسي المستمره حركه منذ سنوات طويله
والتي تدور فيها الكويت سببت كثيرا من
توقف التنميه هنا في الكويت وفي البلاد
وبالتالي خلقت يعني حاله من التململ بين
الكويتين ولذلك لم تستطع ان تنتهي او حاله
التوتر المستمر بين السلطه التشريعيه
والتنفيذيه هي ما تدفع حفله صاحب القرار
هنا في الكويت الى اتخاذ قرار اما بحل
المجلس او البرلمان ولكن في كل هذه
الاحوال هناك محاولات لاخراج برلمان ايضا
يكون يعني يؤدي ينجح الكويتيين ويحاول ان
يعيد حاله التعاون بين السلطتين او
التعاون المفقود هذا بين السلطتين
التشريعيه والتنفيذيه هناك استحقاقات حياه
بدعه من النتائج التي ستحضر او يعني منتصف
ليله غد ان شاء الله ستكون هناك نتائج
اوليه لهذا البرنامج وسنكون معك في
المتابعه سادس الصعيدي مدير مكتب الجزيره
في الكويت شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قالت القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه ان
اسرائيل سلمت مصر جثمان الجندي المصري
الذي قتل ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين في معبر
العوجه وافادت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيليه ان
المجند يدعى محمد صلاح وعمره 22 عاما وكان
يسكن في القاهره
في واشنطن قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
الحادثه تذكر بالمخاطر التي يواجهها
الاسرائيليون بشكل يومي حسب تعبيره
على مدى السنوات الماضيه ادى تصاعد موجه
العنف المروعه بشكل ماساوي الى فقدان
ارواح عشرات المدنيين من كلا الجانبين هذا
العنف يجب ان ينتهي وان يحاسب مرتكبوه
بموجب القانون بشكل متساوي الاعمال
الارهابيه الاخيره بما في ذلك اطلاق نحو
الف صاروخ تجاه اسرائيل تظهر التهديد
اليومي الذي يواجهه الاسرائيليون والحادث
المميت الذي وقع على الحدود مع مصر والذي
اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين هو
تذكير ماساوي اخر بهذه المخاطر
اذا كما قلنا كشفت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
هويه وصور الجنديه المصري الذي قتل ثلاثه
جنود اسرائيليين عند معبر العوج الحدودي
فجر السبت الماضي لكن افور اعلان هذا
النبا تصدر اسم الجندي المصري اهتمام
الشارع العربي وتداولت الوف الحسابات على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي صور الجندي الشاب
الذي يدعى محمد صلاح لكم تقريرا حول هذا
الامر من ماجد عبد الهادي
وفي اليوم الثالث تسرب اسمه عبر مصادر
الصحافه العبريه وعرف الناس من يكون رغم
التكتم المشدد على هويته فتعالت صيحات
الفخر ومعها عبارات الدعاء الى الله
ليشمله برحمته على السنوف المصريين والعرب
كما تكدست صوره على حسابات رواد الاعلام
الاجتماعي في المساحه الشاسعه الممتده من
المحيط الى الخليج حتى بات محط الانظار
بوصفه رمزا وطنيا وقوميا ولد محمد صلاح
الشاب المصري الذي قتل السبت الماضي ثلاثه
جنود اسرائيليين قبل ان يقتله اخرون منهم
في عين شمس قرب العاصمه المصريه القاهره
عام 2001 او وفق حساب زمني اخر بعد مرور
ازيد من عقدين على اتفاقيات كام ديفيد
التي ابرمتها مصر مع اسرائيل عام
1978 وكان من المفترض ان تنهي الحرب وترسي
عهد السلام والتعاون والتطبيع بين الانظمه
كما بين الشعوب هو ليس الاول طبعا الذي
يقدم على عمل فردي فيربك حسابات اقليميه
ويفرض اعاده النظر الجدي فيما ظنه بعض
قاده المنطقه والعالم او صنفوه في قائمه
منجزاتهم على طريق تغيير التاريخي قبله
كان هناك اخرون اقدم على فعل مماثل اشهرهم
المصري سليمان خاطر الذي قتل مجموعه من
الاسرائيليين في سيناء عام 85 فاعتقل
ليحاكم محاكمه عسكريه ثم قيل انه مات
منتحرا في زنزانته وكذلك الاردني احمد
الدجامسه الذي نفذ عمليه مشابهه عام 97 اي
بعد ثلاث سنوات من ابرام معاهده السلام
بين بلاده واسرائيل فاعتقل وحكم عليه
بالسجن المؤبد ثم اطلق سراحه بعد مرور 20
عام
[تصفيق]
لكن هناك فرقا يستدعي التامل بين عمليه
محمد صلاح وعمليات السابقيه من الجنود
العرب الذين تمردوا على السلام الرسمي بين
دولهم واسرائيل كان سياق السنوات التي
سبقت عبور الجنديه المصري الشاب تحصينات
عسكريه معقده ليقتل الجنود الاسرائيليين
الثلاثه قد اكتسم بتفشي تطبيع مع اسرائيل
في اجزاء عده من العالم العربي رغم اتجاه
الدوله اليهوديه كما تسمى نفسها نحو
التطرف او حتى العنصريه في راي كثيرين
واستمرارها بل امعانها في شن الحروب
المتكرره على الشعب الفلسطيني وقمعه وقتله
وتهويد مقدساته بينما كان سياق الهجومين
المشابهين الذين نفذهما خاطر والدجامس
يتمثل في انهما جاء حين كان النظام الرسمي
العربي عموما ما زال على بعض حياء او تردد
في القبول بفكره دمج اسرائيل في نسيج
المنطقه ويتمسك ولو ظاهريا بما كان يسمى
مبدا الارض مقابل السلام اي رفض الاعتراف
بدوله الاحتلال ما لم تنفذ قرارات الشرعيه
الدوليه التي تقضي بانسحابها من الاراضي
المحتله عام 1967
مجددا سيكتشف دعاه السلام او التطبيع
المجاني والحال هذه ان قرابه نصف قرن من
سعيهم الحفيف لتغيير مسار التاريخ بما
يلبي شروط القوات التي غيرت الجغرافيا لم
تبدل شيئا في المزاج الشعبي العربي العربي
الذي مازال اسرائيل دوله احتلال عنصري
ويعتقد بان عليها دفع الثمن عن كل ما
اقترفات طال الزمن او قصر
[موسيقى]
في فقره المتابعه من حصاد الليله نعود بكم
من جديد للملف النووي الايراني والتحديدا
اعلان المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه تركيب اجهزه مراقبه للتخصيب
في منشاتين ايرانيتين
نوويتين للمره الاولى هذا الامر يتعلق
اولا بمجمع فوردو الذي يقع الى الجنوب
بمدينه قم ويبعد عنها نحو سبعه واربعين
كيلو مترا وجزء كبير من هذه المنشا يقع
بالفعل تحت الارض المنشاه الثانيه هي
منشاه التي يقصدها طبعا الرفاهيه وتم
تركيبه اجهزه مراقبه فيها هي محطه النوويه
في مدينه اصفهان والتي سبق ان تعرضت الى
عدد من الحوادث والهجمات
اعاده تثبيت معدات المراقبه مع صدور
التقرير جديد للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه يشير الى ان مخزون ايران من
اليورانيوم المخصب ارتفع باكثر من الربع
في ثلاثه اشهر فقط اما تطور اللافت الاخر
فهو تاكيد الوكاله انها تتحقق من ردود
الايرانيه تلقتها حول ما تعرف بالمواقع
الثلاثه غير المعلنه وهي ما روان ورمين
وتوركوز بادر والتي كانت موضعه تحقيقات
منذ سنوات بعد العثور على ما يعتقد انها
اثار مواد مواد مشعه فيها
ظلت اذا مساله اعاده تثبيت اجهزه مراقبه
التخصيب في المنشات النوويه الايرانيه
قضيه خلافيه بين طهران والوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه حتى الصيف الماضي عندما
تعثرت جهود اعاده احياء الاتفاق النووي
الايراني لكن في ابريل
الماضي اعلن مدير الوكاله رافايا القروسيا
انه سيتم البدء بتركيب الكاميرا واعاده
توصيل بعض معدات المراقبه عبر الانترنت
الوكاله تعتقد ان العمليه التي انطلقت
بالفعل ستستغرق اسابيع وستزيد من قدره
المفتشين الدوليين على مراقبه برنامج
ايران النووي لكن في ظل غياب ومعدات
المراقبه لم تفتا الوكاله تحذر في
تقاريرها المتعاقبه من النشاطات النوويه
الايرانيه في عدد من المنشات الايرانيه
تقرير الوكاله الذي صدر في فبراير الماضيه
اشار لان مخزون طهران من اليورانيوم
المخصب تجاوز ثمانيه عشره مره السقف
المسموح به وفق الاتفاق النووي معنى من
مدينه ليزا البريطانيه دكتور علم صالح
استاذ الدراسات ايران والشرق الاوسط في
الجامعه الوطنيه الاستراليه
يعني هنالك نقاط كانت نقاط خلاف كبيره تم
تجاوزها بسرعه
والسياق الذي تم تجاوز فيه هذه الخلافات
او السياق رسائل كثيره بين واشنطن وبين
طهران وخطوات كبيره على الارض برايك ما
حدث من تقدم مع الوكاله هو انعكاس لما حدث
من تقدم مع طيران بين طهران و واشنطن
ايام نشاط الاتحاد السوفيتي في هذا الموقع
وقبلت الوكاله بهذا التفسير ما تفسيرك انت
لهذا القبول بالتفسير الايراني
لا شك ان هذا الامر كان يجب ان يتفق عليها
الجهتين قبل سنوات ولم يكن من الصعبه
للوصول الى هذا التوافق حول المنشات او او
المسائل العالقه حول المنشات او اي ملفات
النوويه العالقه بين الطهران والوكاله كان
من السهل ان يتفقا حول هذا قبل سنوات ولكن
هذا التزامن هذا الامر مع الوساطه
العمانيه والقطريه بين طهران واشنطن وخلق
اتصالات بين العاصمتان ان دل على شيء
الاتفاق كانت سياسيا الان قبل ان تكون
تقنيا يعني من الامور وصلت الى حد بعيد
لدرجه ان غراس يرد على نتنياهو
واتهاماته ويقول ان الوكاله محايده وليست
منحازه لايران
برايك
العامل الاسرائيلي هل تم تلفيه فيما يتعلق
بالت قدم بين واشنطن وطيران
نعم الان مشكله الولايات المتحده والغرب
والوكاله هي اسرائيل قبل ان تكون ايران
للوصول الى اتفاق النووي عادل وشامل كما
حصل في 2015
اسرائيل هي ترى نفسها الان منعزله سياسيا
وامنيا وخاصه
تزامن هذا التقدم النووي بين ايران والغرب
مع مع تغييرات اساسيه في المنطقه
اي تحسين العلاقات بين الطهران والدول
والدول في المنطقه فهذه ايضا ترعب وتغلق
اسرائيل كثيرا في اسرائيل تريد تسييس
وامننت الملف النووي الايراني
للضغط على ايران قبل اي شيء
دكتور علم صالح من ليدز استاذ دراسات
ايران والشرق الاوسط في الجامعه الوطنيه
الاستراليه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
هذا الطفل يقول كنت مع ابني في السياره
ذاهبين لزياره بعض الاقارب لكن فجاه
اصبتوا انا وابني الاب هو هيثم التميمي
يتحدث عن ابنه محمد هيثم التميمي عمره فقط
عامان فارق الحياه اليوم جراء اصابته
بعيار ناري اطلقت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الخبيث الاب يعتقد ان اطلاق
النار كان من برج مراقبه عسكري اسرائيلي
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انما حدث عند مدخل
قريه النبي صالح شمل الضفه الغربيه
المحتله كان ردا من الجنود على مصدر اطلاق
نار تختلف التفاصيل وتبقى الخساره الفادحه
والم رحيل الطفل في حضن ابيه الم
وللمفارقه يتزامن مع الام تجددها الذكرى
السادسه والخمسون لحرب 67 شكرا لحسن
المتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]